it's hard to believe it's been more than
30 years since James Cameron made the
Terminator but several movies down the
line the franchise has lost its steam
Cameron told an amazing story across
Terminator and Terminator 2 Judgment Day
but not all franchises are meant to run
for three decades here's a look at why
Hollywood won't make another Terminator
movie defective hardware let's be real
the past few sequels were pretty much
total train wrecks things started to go
downhill with 2003's Terminator 3 rise
of the machines
the first without Cameron at the helm
[Music]
talk to the hand
the decline continued with 2009's
Terminator Salvation which despite the
presence of splashy action director
McGee somehow managed to make the future
battle with Skynet utterly boring who
are you John Connor that necessitated
the full-on reboot in 2015's Terminator
Genisys which was met with such critical
disdain and box office indifference that
planned sequels were cancelled yuck
cursed without Cameron the first two
films are awesome for one obvious reason
and no it wasn't naked Arnold
Schwarzenegger who clothes give them to
me now so when Roger director James
Cameron decided to leave the franchise
after Terminator 2 Judgment Day
Hollywood should have probably just left
well enough alone and ended the series
right there it's telling the Cameron
says he's not a big fan of the sequels
that followed as he doesn't feel they've
lived up to that potential and without
Cameron they probably never will
disenfranchised one big issue with the
series is that it wasn't designed to be
a series at all both the original film
and Terminator 2 weren't really about
time travel but instead focused on how
knowledge of the impending Armageddon
affected the characters Sarah Connor
found her inner strength the Terminator
found his humanity John discovered his
destiny no amount of modern special
effects can disguise the fact that the
sequels are missing the heart of the
original films instead they've relied on
increasingly bloated confusing and
convoluted plots Trading humanity for
incomprehensible spectacle without the
original film's focus on what it means
to be human the sequels are destined to
be pale imitations rather than
these successors are Nold other than
James Cameron the major driving force
behind the franchise's Arnold
Schwarzenegger you have to give him
credit for suiting up yet again and
Terminator Genisys despite the fact that
he was pushing 70 but even he has his
limits and the time is fast approaching
when he'll no longer be able to pull off
a terminator film and what fans really
want to see more sequels without him
given how little moviegoers have wanted
to see the last budge even with him
present in the cast making more sequels
without Arnold seems like a losing
formula oh goodbye
hmm this time you probably won't
terminator fourteens the first two
Terminator films were there are ratings
like a badge of honour catering to
adults with dark stories not afraid to
feature some violence and language but
the last two films diluted the series
softening enough to earn a pg-13 rating
that allowed a larger potential audience
sure but it also alienated longtime fans
by smoothing the titles hard edges and
dumbing down the action pandering is
never going to result in better movies
oh oh great that's just great I did not
kill him factory reset it turns out if
you keep churning out bad movies the
public will eventually stop turning out
to see them who knew the past few
Terminator films have failed to generate
much box office buzz despite ballooning
budgets and massive marketing campaigns
Terminator 3 pulled in 150 million in
the US and it only went downhill from
there Terminator Salvation made 125
million in the US and the latest sequel
Terminator Genisys scored a mere 89
million ouch
Hollywood leans unknown franchises
because they're more bankable brands
than unknown commodities but sometimes
even the name brands run out of steam in
the wake of Genesis failure the smart
money is sadly no longer on terminator
no fate but what we make though the
situation looks dire now there's still
hope come with me if you want to live
the reason the rights to the Terminator
revert back to Cameron in 2019
while he's currently busy with those
long-promised avatar sequels it's
possible he might eventually make
another Terminator film himself and if
not you can bet that he'll be very
careful just to e licenses the rights to
with Cameron regaining creative control
over the franchise one thing is sure if
there are never any more Terminator
movies that also means there won't be
any more bad Terminator movies we'll
count that as a win thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our youtube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]